moving on to the next topic today we're
going to be taking a look at a video of
a woman who she basically got taken on a
date by a guy and he bought her to the
Cheesecake Factory which is I think is
like a I don't know if they actually do
cheesecake but I think it's like a CGI
Fridays type as well yeah that's what
I've heard anyway it's a restaurant
nonetheless and this lady got taken to
this restaurant and she is very unhappy
with her situation right even though
she's on a date and you you would think
it would be ladylike and polite to just
be happy to be on the date mhm but uh
she seems to have a different idea let's
let's take a
lookoo all right let me just get the
door for you
okay he got me at the Cheesecake Factory
y'all I a get not
this
yes uh would you want me to open the
door for
you you're recording me
yeah yeah this is the Cheesecake
Factory this is the Cheesecake Factory
y'all what's the problem with that this
is a chain restaurant who takes someone
that looks like this to a chain
restaurant you want to talk about it I'm
I'm f with talking
even in front of them oh yeah I want to
talk about it come on get on in the car
yeah we going to talk about
it so you expect a man to go all out on
the first day is that right I mean
you're supposed to look at I mean it's
but I mean I feel like I'm doing
everything I'm supposed to do as a
woman I got myself all made there's
nothing wrong with The Cheesecake
Factory right yes there's a lot wrong
with The Cheesecake Factory look well
look at I mean look at my plan where we
were we were going to go originally see
now that's that's where that's where we
should have went all right right there
call them call them no what do you mean
though see I physically told you both
yesterday and this morning you didn't
even come downstairs for another hour
and so I was waiting downstairs I
understand but I wasn't expecting for
work to take me so long I got home a
little late and like I said I don't know
you well enough enough to invite you up
into my apartment that is not possible
and that's why I'm saying I'm thinking
okay if we're not there in the
relationship to you know meet at your
apartment then maybe we're not ready in
a relationship for such a nice fancy Rel
uh restaurant as Arya especially if I'm
paying for the whole
thing
wow yeah speechless at that it's just
the entitlement you know she she's she's
admitting to to everything that she did
wrong and she's saying that she's not
ready for him to come up to her
apartment so he says okay fine if we're
if we're not ready for that then maybe
you're not ready for me to Splash all my
money out on a fancy date and I think
that's fair enough yeah I think I
understand what she's saying on a first
date you don't want someone you don't
want me anyway I would sort of feel a
bit uncom having a man come into my
place because obviously you know it
leads to things and but be on time then
cuz he's saying he was waiting for her
for a whole hour so be on time you if
you don't want him coming inside your
flat be on time be downstairs at the
right time that you both agreed to be
there for and you know go on a date
don't keep him waiting around because
then yeah he's not going to take you to
a fancy restaurant he's going to take
you to the Cheesecake Factory and also
I'm sorry but have you did you see what
are you thinking what I'm thinking she's
saying she's doing everything that she
should be doing for a woman and she's
basically acting like she's a tent yeah
when she's very clearly not a tent I
mean she was like does it look like I
belong in the Cheesecake Factory yes
kind of yeah you look like pretty much
any other girl like you're you're
nothing special and from what I know of
the Cheesecake Factory it's just a
normal restaurant I'm trying to think of
what the equivalent is over here maybe
like Harvester or like I have never
heard you've never heard of harvester
have you you like Lola's cupcakes
sure even Lola's cupcakes I think that's
a bit expensive I
know but I mean we can both agree she is
acting like she is the type of woman
that
is we're talking a nine a 10 a model
she's just not and I think something
really important to note here is this
woman is not interested in this man not
even remotely yeah you can tell because
if she was interested in him he could
have taken her anywhere
okay women when they are interested in a
man it doesn't matter where you are
you're just grateful to be around him I
remember when me and my boyfriend first
started dating he he made a joke once
and he was like uh I'm taking you to the
Golden Archers and I thought oh my God
that sounds so like fancy I I'd never
heard this joke before I'd never heard
McDonald's be referred to as the Golden
Archers so I was like wow like what's
the golden arches um and we turned up at
McDonald's and when he said it I was
kind of thinking like I'm not dressed
for a Golden Archers type place like
what is this place and then we T up at
McDonald's and Not only was I relieved
because I thought you know I am not
dressed for a fancy place but you were
happy it didn't matter because I was
just happy to be with him yeah it wasn't
about where we was going and any girl
who's actually interested in a guy it
doesn't matter where you are it doesn't
matter what you're doing it could be a
walk in the park it could be a coffee it
could literally be anything you're just
happy to be around them so you know I
think this guy has dodged a bullet here
definitely she was using him of course
she's using him and she probably does
this to to many guys yeah and you can
tell just from her entit entitlement and
her attitude the type of woman she is
but uh yeah these These are what the
comments are saying he should have just
taken her to a factory forget the
cheesecake
part get her doing some hard labor with
that dollhous mindset it's true
completely agree I'd love to watch
that part
two another one says she looks dressed
for McDonald's she's lucky
yeah yeah she looks dressed like she's
going to The Cheesecake Factory she does
though that's what I said like you know
it's nothing special she doesn't look
dressed up um so I'm a bit confused as
to why she thinks that she belongs in a
fancy restaurant when she doesn't even
and this is what we're doing to women is
that we're telling all women you can be
a 10 we're telling all women Beauty has
nothing to do with about we're telling
all women Beauty has nothing to do with
how you look beauty is a feeling and as
long as you can emulate that feeling of
empowerment and self-love and confidence
then that somehow equates to how you
look on the outside but the reality is
you look how you look it's good if you
are happy within your own skin I I would
never wish for anyone to be
uncomfortable in their own skin but you
look how you look and that is a fact and
you just have to accept your
circumstances for what they are be
grateful that you are in the position
that you are because let's not forget
you know you might not be the prettiest
person in the world but not everyone can
use their arms and legs you know exactly
there's always going to be someone worse
than you and we've seemed to have fallen
prey to this mindset of of teaching
girls that we're on a pedestal and that
all men have to kind of flock and climb
on top of each other to try anything we
want yeah and it it expects nothing of
the women which is completely unfair to
the men and I actually feel really bad
for this guy cuz he's he's waited around
an hour for her he's bought her
somewhere and he even got out of the car
to open the door for her oh I didn't
even see that he got out of the car he
says do you want me to open the door for
you but she had locked the door to his
car yeah that's crazy you can tell he's
so genuine and she's just like deluded
but she looks like mentally ill I don't
know it's kind there's kind of something
weird there the way she's filming
herself the entire time and making faces
like she's a celebrity yeah it's really
like I think she's deluded in more ways
than one like she thinks she's better
than she is as well which is also a
delusion I think what's scary is the
fact that she's not a rare type of woman
I think what's scary is the fact that
there's probably loads of these videos
out there this just happens to be one
that's that's blown up there we go